on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight our Facebook organized censored
Dr Jordan Peterson's interview on this
show has been viewed 17 million times
around the world tonight he's back for
more plus millions of Brits pay tribute
to our Armed Forces every year by
wearing a poppy is it right to shame
those who don't or debate that with SAS
Hero at Middleton and as crucial U.S
mid-sum elections and the no clear
winners or losers but Donald Trump are
both parties now stuck with aging
leaders that nobody wants
[Music]
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
ladies Rolanda welcome to Piers Morgan
on Center the right to protest is
fundamental to any democracy we've got
every right to make demands of the
people who are supposed to service and
every right to make a nuisance when they
don't protest movements go to civil
rights gay rights to female vote they
shape the Free World that we live in
today there's a kind of Golden Rule of
protesting it's a pretty easy one to
remember don't be a dick
just as you have a right to protest
everybody else has the right to go on
living their lives because the chances
are they're not the people that you're
protesting about the brats from just
stop oil have forgotten that Golden Rule
they seem to be taking great pride and
joy in causing daily havoc and misery
for British commuters by shutting down
motorways and in some cases the
consequences have been appalling first a
police officer was injured and two
lorries crashed trying to avoid a
roadblock and then came this
I was actually due to be a polar bear on
my father's coughing along with my son
and we both got
that taken away from us there's nothing
that we could have done
someone that I don't know has taken that
ability for me to say farewell to my
father away from me
that's disgusting
he went on to say you'll never forgive
them and I don't blame him how could he
he had to ring his mother and say he
wasn't going to be there at the funeral
of his father where he was going to
carry the coffin and nor could he bring
his children
that man's grandchildren they all missed
the funeral
you can't do it again
what did he do wrong
to deserve that what do any of the
people who've missed work lost money
missed very important medical
appointments what did they all do wrong
just stop oil wants more action on
climate change so do I
but they're the wrong victims and
they're going about this the wrong way
the point of protest is to put pressure
on the powerful to change calls to do
that you need to have public support
it's democracy that's why we have civil
rights gay rights and the female vote
but what kind of protests like this what
it does is to infuriate and irritate the
very people that is supposedly trying to
persuade if just stop oil wants anyone
to listen to them well let me give them
some very very simple advice
stop being dicks
well joining me now are environmentalist
north of Stanley Johnson talked to
representative Richard Tyson talk to you
the international editor Isabel oshop
and across the pond Fox News contributor
Kat tips who's on the hottest show on
television
Gutfeld well I don't know you claim all
the credit for that cat and quite
rightly
um what comes in a moment cat talking
about the U.S mid test but first of all
Stanley Johnson you're a big
environmentalist but I believe in
climate change I think it's real I think
it's dangerous I think that the world is
heating up and we have to do something
about it uh but I think that what is
going on now with these just stop oil
protests is crossing a line and it's not
having any good impact they're not
changing people's minds that if anything
the alienating people I think what you
say is you know pretty fair
I by the way have addressed meetings in
Trivago Square wearing the extinction
Rebellion badge I think there is a case
for peaceful pressure some of the great
achievements in this world have been
achieved through peaceful process I
looked at film this afternoon of the
lady who threw herself under the the
king's horse I think it was May 20 May
1913 in in in decent town that she went
to prison
you can't always keep everybody happy
all the time but yes I think you're
absolutely right who we're trying to
influence we ought actually being trying
to influence the members of parliament
who have a chance to do the right thing
in terms of influencing the government
this is where the target ought to be and
I think that the way organizations do go
about it for example I'm involved in the
moment in a huge campaign to try and
stop the government scrapping all the
environmental laws which they they want
to do but you know but they say at their
best but but the way that has been done
is by getting lots and lots of people to
write to their MPS so yes I think you're
right about this you do alienate people
and you particularly them Elliott and if
you break the law and break the law in a
way that this right and that's about the
problem is the police haven't really
been tackling them hard enough in my in
my estimation there are many other
countries in the world but this would
not be happening if people Block
motorways in many European countries
actually they'd be in very short Thrift
slung off
um but we've seen oddly reluctant I mean
I'm not reluctant you know you give me a
water can and I'd be the first in there
no I think we've got to get much tougher
this is going to go on and on they've
made it very clear that they're going to
go go on and on doing it I mean standard
you characterize this as peaceful uh
protests I'm not sure that that actually
is peaceful it's causing an immense
amount of disruption it's not peaceful
when policemen start being hit in car
crashes right well it is about in in
Iran at the moment a lot of ladies are
taking off their their scars yes but I'm
sure the Iranian regime thinks that's
illegal it causing disruptions which is
what I mean well no I don't I don't
accept that as equivalents whatsoever
and the whole suffragette thing is
absolutely ridiculous a very clever
piece of spin on the part of these
protesters absolutely no equivalence
whatsoever the suffragettes were
completely disenfranchised that just
stop oil protesters have a vote there
are other ways and also Richards they're
also a lot of what they're calling for
is simply unworkable and then they want
all fossil fuel work to stop overnight
it's insane because we can't afford to
do that and it's not practically
possible anyway everybody accepts who is
frankly saying that we're in a
transition period we don't know how long
that transition is it might be 30 years
it might be 40 years but for example gas
and oil are the key fossil fuels that
are part of that transition what they're
asking for is impossible it's illogical
and the truth is would be much better
actually to use our own fossil fuels
than importing them literally halfway
across the world creating more CO2 more
emissions than actually using ourselves
so what they're asking for is completely
illogical yes the right to protest is
secretary but not the right to obstruct
not the right to prevent people going
about their daily lives and
if for example going to a funeral of
your parents yeah carrying your father's
Gothic I mean I just think that the fact
that man wasn't able to do that is
really disgraceful
come back to Richard's point it's very
nice to hear you say which you think
that the climate change is important as
we speak today they're trying to deal
with this in kindergarten charm or shape
the answer is globally we are Ensure in
in tremendous trouble what Glasgow said
was we've got to keep it to 1.5
nowadays it looks as they were heading
firmly for 2.8 what is happening in in
Sean will take at the moment is
tremendously important Rishi sunak was
there Boris was there it is but the key
thing Stanley this has to be done
sensibly you can't just get rid of all
use of fossil fuels overnight right you
have to move to Green energy in a way
which actually is practical can happen
you need the will of governments to do
it but ultimately it's got to be
practical you can't just stop it what do
you mean by practice
is it's got to be affordable it's got to
be proportionate and what you can do is
penalize the least well-off in society
who can't afford to heat they can't
afford to eat our businesses can't
afford to be competitive and therefore
they're all going over is and what
you've got to be really careful of
Stanley is the only zero is the amount
of money left in our bank accounts right
okay look I want to move on I want to
move on uh to Captain over in New York
cat um the midterms have they're still
dragging on it's quite strawberry to be
in America some of these votes take
weeks or months to resolve to count
what's the matter with you can't you
count over there
yeah that's not my call I'm not involved
in that aspect of things
what are you making remember we used to
have election night what go ahead what
do you make of the midterms I mean it
seemed to me that the big loser looked
like it was Donald Trump certainly the
media has been playing that aggressively
uh and this billion now a battle for the
soul of the Republican Party between
Trump and probably Ron DeSantis who had
a fantastically successful election
result what do you make of that I mean
Trump's got this big announcement coming
next week is he actually going to go
ahead now and say he's going to run or
do you think smarter wiser voices might
be able to persuade him to at the very
least weight
it's been very difficult for anyone to
persuade him of anything uh I think when
it comes to his candidates the strategy
of focusing on you know election denial
and saying the election was stolen it's
not a good one and a lot of people talk
about how it's not a good one because if
you don't believe it you might not want
to vote for Canada candidates who do
believe it but one thing that people
don't talk about which I always think
about is what if people do believe it
why would they want to participate in an
election exactly it's going to be stolen
anyway yeah uh and what we've seen in
the wake of these midterms that we
haven't seen before is the kinds of
people and the number of people who are
saying Trump's got to stop this and if
he can't stop it he's got to go I mean
even Mike cernovich was tweeting that
former Trump advisors were tweeting that
uh it's not just that what people are
saying so much as the people who are
actually saying this stuff that always
had his back in the past no matter what
he said or no matter what he did Joe
Biden would be 80 at the next election
but he's now dropping heavy hints he
wants to run again for another four
years I mean assuming he even makes it
to the next election which I think at
the moment is an aspiration uh I don't
mean that to be unkind just just the
condition he appears to be in when he
appears in public he's increasingly
unsteady
um is he good for America that you may
end up with a president that old
yeah it's I they're things that you see
are very impossible to ignore not just
him stumbling over his words but we've
seen him shaking hands with people who
are not there we've seen him looking for
people who are already dead that's not
something that inspires confidence in
anyone I mean my grandparents have about
10 years on Joe Biden and I just saw
them last weekend and if I saw them do
any of those things I would be deeply
concerned in asking if they needed to go
to the hospital and they are not in
control of the country yes I think
that's the problem they're not they're
not in control of nuclear weapons that's
what worries made right now I want to
talk to you about kangaroo testicles
which I know probably are your that's
your surprise you're you're probably
your experience for that I'll tell you
why because a gentleman called Matt
Hancock who may not have crossed over to
to the American Zeitgeist in quite the
way he has him he was the health
secretary in the pandemic uh was pretty
disastrous for much of it and then he
got fired from his job because he was
caught having an affair in government
buildings breaking his own lockdown
rules he's now popped up in a reality
television show called I'm a celebrity
get me out of here which is notorious
for making you know normally zedless
celebrities go into a jungle in
Australia and do disgustingly
humiliating things at the volition of
the voting public including 18 kangaroo
testicles and he's doing this while he
should be serving his constituents back
in West Suffolk as a member of
parliament for which he receives a
salary of 84 000 pounds so I guess my
question for you is
if this was happening in America if you
had a serving Congressman or woman or
senator who basically took a month out
five weeks out to go to a jungle and eat
kangaroo testicles what would be the
reaction
I would be torn I mean with this guy it
kind of sounds as though perhaps he'd be
better off there than influencing policy
that he right he was saying that you
can't have Gatherings of two people
people couldn't see dying relatives but
he could have an affair with his
assistant I mean an affair is never a
good look when you get busted for one
especially not when you have to
apologize for I'm sorry I broke social's
distancing rules exactly I don't know if
people in Australia would want him
anywhere near the government they might
be happy he's out in the jungle well I'm
going to play a little Montage now for
viewers who've not been caught up to
speed he was he went in last night and
we have a montage of the former Health
secretary here he is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the man that put the [ __ ] into Hancock
um well look I'm not gonna go at you
again Isabel about the fact you've done
a book with him well we'll save that for
when the book comes out but when I
watched it last night I I can see though
to my horror various people were
messaging me saying she's coming over
okay which of course is exactly what he
wants but if I'd lost a relative in the
pandemic and there hasn't even been a
proper inquiry yet into what the
government did right or wrong in the
pandemic this looks to me like just a
running smack in the face to those
people that he's making all this money
doing humiliation eating things making a
total pass of himself frankly
um but for you know self-promotional
reasons and fulfilling his bank balance
and he's going to have to live with the
consequences of what was an incredibly
high risk decision and I think it will
be really interesting I'm sure Stanley
will have a perspective on the dynamic
in the jungle to see how that plays out
because already last night and by the
way I've never watched I'm a celebrity
before this series is huge everyone's
everyone is tuning in to watch him get
humiliated it's absolutely extraordinary
um but you can already see some tensions
there there's Boy George in there who
clearly his mother had been very ill I
can see him Brewing to have a go there's
others might Tyndall didn't look too no
he doesn't Charlie White lost her
clearly the vibe in the in amongst the
other celebrities was pretty hostile to
him so at some point I don't know is
this going to blow up or is it going to
go the other way because he's going to
go the other way yeah I think it's going
to go the other way I'm going to warm to
this I think I'm in a minority again I
suspect here but I think people are
going to walk and first first they're
going to think actually who has put
dyslexia on everybody's you know
standing there he's talking about
he wants to pretend it's about dyslexia
sorry what no one is talking about
dyslexia I'm sorry we've been nothing
nothing but dyslexia being talked about
recently it's not to do with Matt
Hancock I suppose he's putting he's put
it on him being covered in slime
honestly that is absolutely racist so
that's it and B and B I think we are
going to see people say look you know
he's doing a good job he's actually in
the jungle
dive him down into disgusting quarries
of slime all I want is a good job I did
17 days there I did 17 days look at this
this is a little bag which says yeah he
says Stanley right and I think this is
all the food we had for for 17 days and
I thought it was you know I thought it
was a good experience good experience
because nobody to talk to um who was no
no don't get me wrong he's perfectly
entitled to have his good experience
Richard says my problem with this is the
time timing right he's perfectly
entitled to be a z-list ex-politician
going to a jungle but not before there's
been a public inquiry into his handling
of a pandemic which is the worst Health
crisis of Our Generation the winners
here is ITV because the viewing numbers
are going through the roof people want
to see him make a fool of himself if he
wants to be a celebrity then please
resign Stand Down from your seat have a
by-election and go and be a zedless
celebrity that's that's his call but the
reality as you say there's a public
inquiry going on at the moment millions
of people suffered terribly as you say
losing relatives not being able to go
and they're suffering now and in his
constituency from his cost of living
living crisis exacerbated by the
conservative government and where's
their MP he's Feathering his nest for
hundreds of thousands of pounds he's not
representing him in the House of Commons
for which he is paid to do right catch
him if he's was Donald Trump and he was
in a jungle and having despicable things
done to him in a very humiliating way
slime on his head and rats and
tarantulas and being hung upside down
and everything else and he could vote as
the American people whether he should
carry on doing this every night and do
these horrible humiliating challenges
probably the biggest TV show of all time
wouldn't it
everybody would watch it nobody would
miss it
but is it right though when you think
this guy you know now you know a bit
more about him is it right you think I
mean if an American politician did this
while they were still serving as a
politician I think there'd be outraged
wouldn't they all right I mean of course
it's not but I think that if you're
gonna actually you know that it's not
and he knew there'd be backlash but
going in and doing it anyway proves how
bad he thought things would be if he was
actually around to take some questions
about this you know what I think there's
absolutely spot on cat great to see you
thank you very much for coming on
appreciate it Stanley always good to
lock horns with you don't agree with
almost anything you ever say but I love
the way you say it Isabel will return to
you when your book comes out
with Matt Hancock hey Richard thank you
for coming on appreciate it well
certainly come uh I'm wearing one out of
choice tonight essay a soldier term
presenter Ann Middleton thinks I
shouldn't have to wear a poppy and only
wokie Warriors would refuse news so next
we're going to debate that also back
from Twitter for supposedly transfer a
bit will your musk have him back Jordan
Peterson returns two clears more than
uncensored life there he is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Peterson is one of the world's most
famous and fascinating intellectuals
books are instant best sellers tens of
millions watch them online in fact his
last interview on Piers Morgan
uncensored so far been viewed more than
17 million times and I'm delighted to
say that he joins me again now uh John
great to have you back on the program
foreign
good to see you again I was absolutely
astonished British maybe I shouldn't
have been but by the reaction to our
last interview worldwide the sheer
volume of people that watch the whole
interview the way the clips were
disseminated on tick tock on Facebook on
Twitter it was a really interesting
Insight actually into a whole world that
doesn't even involve actually
conventional television anymore I guess
you wouldn't be surprised because this
happens to you a lot but I was what does
it say about
society that that number well I want to
talk to you on a computer or phone
well I'm still continually surprised
about it but well I think what it shows
is that there's really no way that
Legacy TV in some real sense can compete
with the absolutely wide open Frontier
of online video distribution where the
cost is low and people can access it
everywhere it's fundamentally the
consequence of a technological
Revolution and there's all sorts of good
things about that and one of those would
be the ability to widely disperse
complex and sophisticated information
which YouTube has been particularly good
at in the long form but it's also
problematic in that it produces all
sorts of alterations and social behavior
that we're only and some of them very
dangerous some many of which were only
just beginning to understand
right Elon Musk has just bought Twitter
and it's creating a huge Ferrari
obviously in many different ways and
he's admitted I'm going to do lots of
things in the next few months and we're
going to get some wrong and we're going
to pull them and try something else he's
going to try and work out a way of
making a sustainable business model but
also he wants to bring back what he
perceives to be genuine free speech on
the platform
um is it possible Jordan do you think
that he can do that or are we now so
entrenched in tribalism particularly on
social media but it's almost impossible
to do what he wants to do
well you couldn't have picked a better
day to talk about this with me because I
just got a paper sent to me today by
Jonathan height he didn't write the
paper it's Paul it would be published
it's published in a journal called
personality and individual differences
and it's an examination of the
personality traits associated with uh
let's say excessive and self-promoting
internet usage and I if you don't mind
I'd like to read you a couple of the
descriptions of what the people found
because it's so absolutely spot on and
relevant I don't think we are descending
into tribalism I think what's happening
is that the virtualization of the world
is enabling
um people who behave in a particular
anti-social way in a self-grandizing and
self-promoting anti-social way and I'll
just read you the descriptions that are
taken directly from this paper so it was
an actual study of online Behavior women
characterized by high self-centered
antagonism neurotic narcissism
Machiavellian views Machiavellian
tactics so that's manipulative
manipulativeness meanness disinhibition
physical sadism and indirect sadism used
Instagram for a longer time and more
frequently than did men in women verbal
sadism and emotionality was is
associated with longer well honesty
humility and conscientiousness was with
a shorter Facebook usage time
furthermore women high in egentic
extroversion so that's manipulative
self-promotion and indirect sadism used
Facebook for a longer time and more
frequently than men
and so I've thought for a while that one
of the things that's happening to us as
we virtualize the world is that we're
enabling the small percentage of people
it's usually about three percent in
general populations
who used manipulation and reputation
savaging and denigration and
self-promotion so the genuinely
Psychopathic types to dominate the
social conversation and to spew their
poisonous and manipulative Venom into
the public domain not only with no fear
of being stopped and no uh and no
inhibition which is almost all applied
socially but also well-being monetized
and promoted by the people who run the
social media channels and every society
forever has had to contend with a small
percentage of people who will utilize
all the benefits of society only for
themselves they had to contend with the
fact that those people if not brought
under control can demolish the structure
of the entire society and I think the
polarization that we're feeling is a
consequence of their untrammeled
expression online Instagram Facebook and
in and in online comment
um
forums like Twitter and that and so that
that stuff you read out just seemed to
be gender specific to women presumably
also applies in other ways to men as
well on social media oh yeah well I I
think the reason that it applied in this
study in women is because Instagram is
very heavy image use image it it
involves heavy use of images and there
are reasons to assume that because of
that it attracts women who are directed
towards short-term impulsive mating
strategies and that's another sign of
impulsive anti-social and Psychopathic
Behavior I think you'd see the same
thing in man in fact I've been talking
to psychologists great psychologists to
make sure that I'm on the right track
here about uh those who post uh
repeatedly say in online forums
especially in relationship to comments
and you certainly see that same pattern
of sadism machiavellianism psychopathy
and narcissism characterizing The Men
Who who are also incentivized to use
what used to be classic female
anti-social strategies to advance
themselves in the reputational hierarchy
but the bottom line exploiters
fundamentally right but the bottom line
is that there is a small percentage of
people generating a vast amount of noise
what impact is that happening on society
do you think
well I think it it skews our perceptions
of what normal people are like we assume
that what we're getting you know when
you sample the world when you're walking
through it you you make the assumption
that you're getting unbiased an unbiased
representation of the things going on
around you and when you're on a plot an
online platform and say reading comments
you also have the assumption that what
you're seeing is something like a sample
of public opinion but it's not you know
because if if 10 strangers came up to
you randomly in the street then you'd
have a bit of a sample of what people
randomly think but Behavior online isn't
random and the people who post aren't
aren't precisely normal and I have been
talking with Jonathan height and Gene
twangy about this and I think they might
know more about it than anybody else in
the world and it's pretty clear that the
people who are dominating say online
comment sections and I would especially
say this is true of the people who post
anonymously and there's other markers
for for this sort of behavior as well
they dominate the political discourse
and what's happening in some sense is
that we have a new form of pollution
that's also corporate sponsored and it's
pollution of the domain of public
discourse and the pollution occurs
because the social media companies are
either enabling or failing to control
you know those known in the popular
parlance is Trolls but they're not just
comical trolls you know using derision
in some cute way and and having their
say in the Free Speech domain they're
really poisonous individuals and they're
poisoning the entire domain
what can Elon Musk do about it if you
were advising him on this I mean
ironically at the moment you're not on
Twitter a would you do you want to come
back now that musk is in charge do you
think you should be restored
um do you want to be back on Twitter and
secondly what would you advise him to do
about this issue of the trolls and so on
well the first thing I would advise and
I'm going to be advising the political
people I'll be talking to over the next
few weeks of precisely this and I have
talked it over with twangy and height to
make sure that I'm not like I said off
on a personal tangent I would say
there's no excuse for including the
anonymous posters with the real human
beings and I think that social media
platforms who have a certain reach maybe
it's a million subscribers and I don't
really know what figure is appropriate
should be required to implement know
your customer laws and then that the
people who are posting who are genuine
verified human beings willing to abide
by their words with their personal
reputation should be put in one comment
section
and then the online Anonymous cowardly
narcissistic pathological troll demons
who are polluting the public discourse
should be put into different common
section and if you want to go to hell
and visit the troll demons and see what
they have to spew you can but otherwise
you can be among the normal human beings
engaged in normal civil human discourse
and that would separate the bloody
Psychopaths from the from the bulk of
decent normal people and you know 97
percent of people aren't Psychopathic
and so we are talking about a small
minority here but they have the upper
hand see actually there's a percentage
of people who I actually I I it's like I
had a psychopath test done on me
actually a lengthy questionnaire and
they concluded I was a good psychopath
and what do they mean by that Excel you
know apparently I wasn't like the
malevolent version it was slightly lost
on me than you okay well okay look look
it's often the case that people in the
industry that you're in and this would
be true for politics and journalism as
well anything with a public face are
more likely to be extroverted
and also more likely to be somewhat
disagreeable and those those personality
traits can tilt you towards uh what
would you say a style of callous
exploitation but there are other
personality factors that mediate against
that like conscientiousness and so
people who are hard-working and reliable
for example aren't parasitic in the same
way that the classic psychopath would be
and so it's complicated and it isn't the
case that extroversion and even a
certain degree of disagreeableness in an
in and of themselves are dangerous but
they lead like everybody's led to
Temptation in the direction that's in
accordance with their temperament and
the fact that you are a public-facing
person and that you like that would tilt
you in one direction of potential
temptation but that's not necessarily
diagnostic now it is a problem because
it probably is the case that politics
and journalism and entertainment attack
attract a disproportionate number of
machiavellians and Psychopaths because
of the of the status that goes along
with those Enterprises but it's not
diagnostic it doesn't mean that if
you're in that industry and you know
you've had a long career and that's also
another marker for failure or for lack
of psychopathy because in nor in the
normal world
Psychopaths exploit and they get a
reputation for doing so quite quickly
and then people avoid them and stop
working with them and so it doesn't work
over the medium to long run as a general
rule
yeah I get it last time we spoke at
length you said afterwards we forgot to
get around to Donald Trump and you were
quite Keen to talk about Donald Trump so
we're gonna take a short break and when
we come back I do want to talk about
Trump because the big question right now
in America is is Trump done so we'll
talk about that after the break
raise your hand if you've ever been
called crazy I don't think that men can
control crazy women
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to Pittsburgh I'm still
here with Dr Jordan Peterson my special
guest tonight uh Jordan Donald Trump
what is he is he a narcissist a
sociopath a psychopath
all of those things none of them
I don't think that he's a psychopath
um because
he's been successful in repeated
Enterprises over long periods of time
and he has a variety of people who are
remain intensely loyal to him now he's
definitely extroverted in a very to a
very great degree and he's definitely
disagreeable and so that gives him some
of the traits that are associated with
those personality features but from what
I've been able to understand he's also
very conscientious and hardworking for
example and so that's a real mitigating
factor and so I think it's it's very
easy to demonize someone that you don't
approve of let's say and certainly Trump
is being subject I would say to more
demonization than any political leader
in the west that I can remember in my
entire lifetime including Richard Nixon
and so that's also set him back on his
heels and made him somewhat embattled in
defensive which I don't think did any
great things for
for his personality in some real sense
so I think it's a mistake to assume that
that Trump is a psychopath I think it's
a big mistake I think it's a big mistake
to assume that Putin is a psychopath
it's easy to do that but I don't think
the evidence suggests that you don't
want to throw those labels around
casually and you know for if if Trump
was Psychopathic well he did a pretty
good job of keeping the United States
clear of War for four years that's
pretty damn remarkable and he did have a
big hand in promoting the Abraham Peace
Accords and that was pretty remarkable
and those aren't the sorts of things
that you would expect
from the psychopath he also seems to
have a pretty good hand with the working
class so I I don't think it's reason
those are those are reasonable
diagnostic labels too you're sounding
like a you know I can't say place on
someone I don't know if it was in your
mouth but you sound like you're you're a
bit of a fan of Donald Trump would you
would you like him to run again would it
be good for America do you think
no I I don't think it would be good for
America would it be good for him to run
that's a diff that's a difficult
question because it might be that it
would be good for America to have
whether or not Donald Trump should be
president sorted out in the public
sphere debated intensely and subject to
an election so it might be very
interesting to see him put himself
forward on the Republican ticket if I
had my druthers
um and I say this I hope with due care I
would rather see someone like DeSantis
step forward who shares some of that
forthright
um strength let's say that characterizes
Trump at his best but seems to be a more
uh cautious administrator and a less
divisive figure I think that would be
better because the Trump for whatever
virtues he might have and I think he has
the virtues of a Washington Outsider I
think that's quite clear I think that
his his behavior in the political realm
raises the political temperature to a
dangerous degree yeah and uh you know I
say that while trying to give the devil
is due and not casting careless
aspersions on his on his name yeah I
know exactly and I want to send to
somebody else who may well have
presidential Ambitions and has been the
subject of a lot of negativity uh Meghan
Markle Prince Harry's wife who does this
podcast uh Archer well podcaster you
know archetypes is cool and when she
seems to perennially play the victim the
female victim of all outrages and your
name got dragged into this let's take a
listen to what she said
raise your hand if you've ever been
called crazy or hysterical
or what about nuts insane out of your
mind completely irrational I don't think
that men can control crazy women the use
of these labels has been drilled into us
for movies and TV from friends and
family and even from random strangers
and the fact is no one wants this label
what did you make of that Jordan to be
suddenly appearing on Meghan markle's
podcast as a villain the first thing I'm
calling women crazy
yeah well the first thing I make of it
is that her voice drips with the same
falsehood that the voice of Kamala
Harris drips with it's this
sanctimonious
um full compassionate talking down to
her audience and trying to be sure that
we're all really on the same
compassionate page here and we're all
being victimized by terrible forces that
are arrayed against us and none of
that's really fair and it's it just
grates on me and I do believe uh you you
played a bit of a clip from me when I
was talking to um
um uh palia uh
Camille pelia the literary critic and I
do believe that it is the case that it's
very difficult to control female
anti-social Behavior often of the type
that's been pilloried as hysterical and
I think that there is no shortage of
clinical evidence to support precisely
that
um claim it's very difficult for women
to control female anti-social behavior
and females who are anti-social that
feminine pattern is reputation salvaging
under the guise of Compassionate Care
and it's it's extraordinarily
destructive and uh
so I stand by my words
and I do think it scales online because
you can use an anonymous reputation
savaging to unbelievably great effect
online with absolutely no punishment for
your sins so to speak and that is
certainly one of the things that's
contributing to so-called Council
culture and there's no shortage of that
coming from the female side now men can
engage in exactly the same strategies
and they do so online and that's enabled
but um it's definitely see with men and
I've said this before and I do believe
this to be the case the the ever-present
threat of the potential for physical
violence
keeps men from doing that to each other
most of the time in person and that all
disappears online and that means that
those who are prone to do such things to
use corrosive and denigration
denigrating derision for example and
reputation savaging can have a free hand
at it and that includes no shortage of
women and women are often very very
often the targets of that behavior from
their own from their own fellows so to
speak we've talked about
um Trump and Meghan Markle I wanted to
just ask you again about Elon Musk about
what you thought of him as a character
he seems to me a fascinating individual
you know whether he's slightly on the
Spectrum or I'm not sure what his makeup
is psychologically but he's certainly a
creative genius a whirlwind a life force
he's done remarkable things what do you
make of him
well I know people who know him very
well and have worked with him very
closely and these are very solid people
extremely competent and extremely
creative and their admirers of Moscow I
talked with my brother-in-law Jim Keller
who's one of the world's great chip
engineers and he worked very closely
with musk for years and he believes that
in he's in many ways exactly what you'd
think he was he's a genius but he's also
like a a Visionary genius but he's also
someone who's very very good at
implementing very good at running
companies as you can tell because he has
a multitude of impossible successful
companies and so he goes into a company
and he cleans house and puts things in
order and makes things work efficiently
and maybe he can do that with Twitter
um I hope he can because
musk is doing all sorts of things that
appear to be useful and difficult and it
would be a catastrophe to see him
derailed in his efforts and I think he
would you like to be back with Twitter
would you like to be back on Twitter
you know I I was I was I dipped into
Twitter this morning uh when I was
looking at some of the research that I
just shared with you and
um it instantly struck me the same way
it struck me the last time I was on
Twitter it's so it's such a den of
pathology that using it I think is
psychologically damaging and if it's
possible for musk to get the the trolls
and they're not trolls they're
Psychopathic Machiavellian sadistic
narcissists under control then it's
possible that the platform might be
useful I like to share information on I
like to follow people to see what they
were up to a lot of the people that I've
met over the years but man it's a snake
pit it is it is obvious to me that we
know what to do about it before I let
you go Jordan you're wearing a poppy I'm
wearing a poppy we're about to have a
debate after the break about whether
people should be compelled to wear
poppies and I guess this goes to the
wider thing about uh General displays of
I guess signaling your virtue in any way
that you choose should anyone be
compelled to whatever the cause whether
it's a black Square on Instagram when
George Floyd died or a poppy for
Armistice Day or so on should people
ever be compelled
I think that that compulsion especially
in matters of public policy is a sign of
bad policy if you can't get people on
board voluntarily by motivating them
with the proper story then you're a poor
leader and so I certainly certainly
would be opposed to anything
approximating legal compulsion now we
use social compulsion frequently to to
produce consensus let's say and to
enforce it and that's never going to go
away and there's some utility in that
but my general Take On The World Is that
people should be allowed to go to hell
in a hand basket pretty much any way
they choose once they're adults although
they might be encouraged not to do that
and invited not to do that but I'm not a
fan of compulsion for any reason I think
it is a sign of bad policy if you and I
can't play together voluntarily then we
don't have a very good relationship and
it's not going to be efficient and
productive Force to continue and I will
take that analysis to commence our
debate uh Dr Jordan Peterson as always
fascinating thank you very much indeed
for joining me
really good to talk to you again Pearson
and uh good to see you and and and thank
you to everyone watching and listening
there was thoroughly Joy come back soon
thank you very much we're coming next so
is it offensive not to wear a poppy
former essay a soldier at middle Tinkers
head-to-head with the mirrors Kevin
McGuire who refuses to wear one it
should be Lively
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
happens
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook downstairs so
the poppy is Britain's national symbol
of remembrance the Armed Forces Heroes
who lose their lives in service of their
country most people wear it with pride
but some people for their own reasons
refuse to and they're often savagely
criticized but should any display of
personal respect ever be mandatory what
joining me now is adventure of former
Marine uh from the SBS plus associated
with Daily Mirror Kevin McGuire Kevin
McGuire very sensibly I noticed not come
into the studio to tell this to Ann
Middleton's face where he would break
your face and you're not wearing a poppy
so explain to me why don't you wear a
poppy and why do you feel the way you do
Pearson is too disciplined uh to uh to
break my case he might want nobody
wouldn't he wouldn't do it now look I'm
happy to buy a poppy and make my
donation I realize the Royal British
Legion make about 50 million pounds a
year or they did before coven it's very
it's very important but it's the
compulsion uh I uh against and the poppy
police finger pointing saying why aren't
you wearing a poppy from the end of
October when TV stations compete to
stick uh poppies in lapels over whoever
appears on them it's almost like
Christmas Comes earlier every year it's
that level of compulsion and I'm in
Exeter which is why I'm not with you and
I'm in London and I've been doing my
survey on the street because I knew
we're going to discuss this most people
are not wearing a poppy I would I would
say at least nine in ten okay probably
more than all right
they're not they're just not doing it
and the argument from Kevin is are they
all disrespectful he doesn't want to
wear one
um why should he
full of respect it's as simple as that
it's a symbol of respect it's a symbol
of remembrance for those that fall
during World War II World War One you
name it for those that are given the
ultimate sacrifice for us to live on
this island for us to be in the UK to us
to live in this privileged society that
we live in and for us to even have the
opportunity to not wear the poppy or to
wear the poppy you know I guarantee you
yeah freedom of choice is guarantee you
everyone has been affected by uh by the
world wars you know even the last
generation is is that is that that close
to us what about people like there's an
Irish footballer called James McLean who
gets regularly criticized and hounded
for not wearing a poppy but he comes
from Derry and he comes from a
particular part of Derry where six
people in that Community lost their
lives on the Bloody Sunday shootings
back in 1972 And he says I cannot wear
but the property the poppy has nothing
to do with uh it does actually represent
all military action by the British Armed
Force the puppy has nothing to do with
with Bloody Sunday it has the Irish Fort
we fought with the Irish we fought with
the the Welsh we fought with the
Scottish you know this island came
together
to fight for the freedom for the people
on the island and for the freedom of the
of of the United Kingdom now we fought
together people are getting glossed and
confused with what they what it
symbolizes it symbolizes the coming
together personal sacrifice remembering
that personal stuff should people be
forced to live freely in this country to
be forced to wear them no they should no
no one should be forced no it shouldn't
be but it should be strongly recommended
now when we see people wearing the white
poppy it's like now you either wear one
or you don't you know the white probably
that just causes divide it's absolutely
ridiculous to even have white poppy out
there Kevin I mean I to me it's it's
look I don't think people should be
mandated to wear one but it does seem
strange to me
um that people seem to make more effort
not to wear one than they do to put one
on it's almost a trend it's a few days
every year where you just remember these
horrendous world wars in particular were
so many millions of people lost their
lives is it too much to just put a poppy
on and say thank you and respect them
I think there's a case peers people
don't like to be told what to do and
they don't like the finger pointing by
the poppy police trying to name and
shame Charlene white the I.T uh n news
reader who's now in the jungle and I'm
I'm a celeb she didn't wear a poppy
because she doesn't wear symbols for a
lot of the other Charities she she
represents she got terrible racist uh
abuse I know the James McLean story
because he used to play for Sunland he's
at Wigan now and he's from he's from
Derry and in Northern Ireland and some
parts of uh of Great Britain too the
poppy is an issue that divides people
and it is because it's connected to the
military and the establishment although
it's trademarked by the Royal British
Legion uh who who have who have the
trademark they get the money it doesn't
go to other Charities it goes for them
it's very important it is it is this
idea of not persuading people but
pointing the thing and saying You must
wear it
it's it's our history it's like I said
our grandfathers and grandmothers were
affected by it it's a mark of respect
for them it's a mark of respect and
Remembrance for those you know what I've
given you you're wearing one you're
wearing one I'm wearing one country and
I actually think we fought for the right
for people like Kevin McGuire they don't
want to wear one they don't have to but
I would prefer they did great to see you
as always that's it from me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign